where's the first place you performed
first time you ever went up on a stage
the first time I ever got on stage
um it wasn't even a stand-up show the
first time I ever got on stage period
was a um a college dating game I was one
of the three or three Bachelor guys
right and I'm gonna tell you something
man I ripped that [ __ ] you know it was
like dare my friends said are we daily
to get in the dating game I said I'll
[ __ ] do it you know I don't I didn't
plan on winning this [ __ ] did you win
them [ __ ] around yeah and I went up
there every answer I gave rocked the
house like I mean rip the house right
and I was like this holy [ __ ] where was
this like a club or no at the Student
Center in college I see every question
she asked me I was just killing them
right that was like holy [ __ ] I'm
killing these mothers I'm killing them I
was going crazy man oh [ __ ] you know and
back then people would stomped their
feet when you [ __ ] do crazy [ __ ]
and [ __ ] right and right and and you
almost have a Out of Body Experience
right like
like my body stepped out of me and said
are you killing these [ __ ] you
know with you there's a certain like no
matter what you say it's kind of funny
to begin with just because you've got a
certain affect you've got a certain
style in your voice it's an attitude do
you do you like this the way you even
pronounce certain words
it's uh is are you aware or do you play
it up for uh do you know what I'm
talking about right if I talk to you
yeah yeah I just did it yeah [ __ ] yeah
you know what I think uh uh you you
accentuate certain words and you have a
Cadence to to what you do but I think
that that keeps people attention you
know what I mean yeah you know
um if you're talking to somebody and
they you see their [ __ ] eyes start
halfway closing you know what I mean
yeah you know you [ __ ] know you
boring the [ __ ] out of this so part of
being part of being a great comedian
part of being a great comedian is
looking at your audience and realize
when you're losing them you can't drone
on right man that's why I refuse I
[ __ ] refuse to go on stage with a
[ __ ] plan ah I [ __ ] never have a
[ __ ] plan is that true you don't have
set material I got bullets in my host
though that I can [ __ ] go to but I'm
not nailed down to that [ __ ] because
here's what I feel I feel like this
any [ __ ] stage you [ __ ] do don't
have a thousand stages around this
[ __ ] country you can perform at every
stage is different every lighting is
different every microphone is different
every sound is different every mic stand
is different the audience is far from
you they're close to you there's so many
[ __ ] things to play with it's a
curtain behind you there's a brick wall
behind you it's a [ __ ] big improv
word behind you there's so many [ __ ]
things sometimes you gotta walk through
the audience to get on stage sometimes
you come out of trap I have a hard time
believing no you [ __ ] love it when
you started out in comedy you didn't
have a little book you wrote down ideas
and then you would sit and perfect that
material and do it night after night of
course yeah I did right but the key word
here Howard I'm not nailed down to that
[ __ ] Howard yeah but like now down to
[ __ ] it's like here's what I feel like
see this is different than Jerry
Seinfeld Jerry Seinfeld says to me he
got a he's got this book and he writes
yeah he writes out the words I improv
the [ __ ] out of my audience because
here's what I feel yeah suppose you got
a [ __ ] joke right go ahead Howard you
got a joke this [ __ ] kills every [ __ ]
way right this [ __ ] this
right and that [ __ ] go-to for
some particular reason right if you left
one little word out left a little segue
out I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
but that audience did not catch that
[ __ ] right they didn't catch it
right and that's your best [ __ ] joke
now you're doomed now you're sitting
there like holy [ __ ] right that's my
best [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do I do
now right you just [ __ ] failed
because you [ __ ] relied on that joke
I see I don't rely on [ __ ] so if I if I
even get to material I don't give a [ __ ]
if I don't get to one mother I don't
give a [ __ ] if I don't get to one joke
the audience will never [ __ ] know
that's not a [ __ ] written joke